Crossing the gulf of execution, and the
gulf of evaluation, involves users asking themselves
a series of questions. For each of
the seven questions, indicate whether the question occurs
at the users goal. The action done to the world. The Gulf of Executiuon. Or
the Gulf of Evaluation. What do I want to accomplish? Or what is my goal?
What action can I do now? How do I do it? And after I've taken action, what just
happened? What does what just happened, mean? Am I
okay with what just happened? Have I accomplished my
goal? It's important to note that typical behavior, is
not about going through all stages in a linear
fashion. We tend to weave back and forth when
trying to accomplish a goal. And not all of
the activity In the seven stages of action, is conscious. Goals tend to be
conscious. But even they may be subconscious.
The seven stages of action that are made
up of the Gulfs of Execution and
Evaluation. Provide a helpful checklist for designers to
use when creating something. And next, Don
introduces important design rules, that are linked to
the seven stages of action.